Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where entrepreneurs
seek an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
I started this business
out of the garage of my home.
Raja: Whatever you do,
don't leave your seats.
Narrator: If the Sharks hear
a great idea...
Whoa!
...they'll invest
their own money...
I think
it's a licensing play.
I think it's an upsell.
...and fight each other
for a deal.
You're the real deal.
Corcoran:
That's an offer from a pig.
Will you shut up,
Barbara?
He's nuts.
She actually isn't
very good with numbers.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must get the full amount
they're asking for, or they'll
walk away with nothing.
We have a patent.
This baby's a chick magnet.
[ Laughs ]
This is a go-to-market
investment opportunity.
This is a prototype.
Oh, my God.
Have you ever played
in the retail space?
No, that's why
I need a partner.
This is a critical moment.
Well, how are you
gonna help me?
Narrator:
Who are the Sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's premier
$2 billion real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, son of
an immigrant factory worker,
founded one of
the world's preeminent
cyber-security firms.
Lori Greiner, the Queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
more than 400 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in sales.
And Mark Cuban,
esteemed billionaire tech mogul
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪
I'm Oliver.
And I'm Sam.
And we're best friends
and business partners
from Denver, Colorado.
We're high school freshmen,
and we've been friends
since preschool.
Sam, what do you think
about this?
I like it.
Oliver: Our moms and dads
are entrepreneurs,
and they've always encouraged us
to think and tinker and invent,
and it's just
really in our blood.
Sam:
One day, Oliver and I
were enjoying one
of our favorite treats,
and an idea came to us --
a solution
to solve a very sticky problem.
Let's make sure
we got the consistency right.
We worked
in my mom's kitchen
to figure out the perfect
mixes and measurements
to make
the best prototype.
Oliver: All right.
Time to bake.
All right.
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Sam Nassif.
And I'm Oliver Greenwald.
Oliver: Our parents
have always told us
you only get one chance to
make a great first impression.
I think we need
a little bit more energy there.
Show our confidence...
Yeah.
...and make sure they get
we mean business.
Oliver:
We've been practicing our pitch
every chance we can get.
We just want to walk
into the Tank really prepared.
Sam: We really know
that we've got a great product
that we can license
to a big manufacturer.
And with a Shark on our team,
we'll be "dripping" with cash.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Sam Nassif.
And I'm Oliver Greenwald.
We're both
from Denver, Colorado,
and our company
is the Drip Drop.
We're seeking $50,000 in
exchange for 20% of our company.
Sharks, everyone loves
eating ice cream.
But there's
a universal problem.
When ice cream melts down
the side of a cone,
you get messy drips all over
your hands and clothes,
and you have to waste
tons of napkins wiping it up.
We knew there had to be
a better way.
That's why we created
the Drip Drop.
Drip Drop is
an edible, useful,
and environmentally friendly
add-on
to the traditional
ice cream cone.
It's such
a simple solution.
Only kids
could have invented this.
It's an edible ring
made out of the same ingredients
as the cone.
You see this?
There's a hole in the middle.
And you slide it
up the ice cream cone like this.
It fits perfectly
and catches all the drips
from your melting ice cream.
It's that easy.
You lick it, eat it, boom!
[ Laughs ]
And take your pick
from many delicious flavors
such as sugar cone...
A classic.
...or chocolate-covered.
Mmm, tasty.
Sharks, we need
your money and advice
to help get the Drip Drop
in every ice cream store
and every mouth
in the world.
Now, don't worry,
Mr. Wonderful.
No one's gonna steal
our cool, new product...
'cause it's
securely patented.
Cuban: Yeah.
Whoo-hoo.
Oliver: That's right.
We may not have driver's
licenses, but we have a patent.
[ Laughter ]
This baby's
a chick magnet.
[ Laughter continues ]
That's awesome.
Oh, that's good.
Sharks,
Drip Drop is simple,
it solves a real problem,
it's environmentally friendly,
it's patented,
and it sure is catchy.
Badum-ch!
Dude, come on.
We can do better than that.
Let me try.
Ice cream drip!
Both:
We scream drop!
And now, Sharks, you can scream
for the Drip Drop.
So, who wants
some ice cream?
We've got
all your favorite flavors.
Yeah.
Cuban: Bring it.
Nice job.
Very well done, guys.
Thank you, Oliver.
Yeah.
-So this is for Lori.
-Ladies first.
Corcoran:
I love coffee.
Thank you.
Smart.
So clever.
So, guys, I got to know.
What was going on
when you came up with it?
Well, three years ago,
when we were in fifth grade,
we were 10 years old.
We entered the Gates Invention
Competition at our school.
And so they challenged us
to solve a problem.
So, one day Oliver and I were,
uh, going to an ice cream store,
and we happened to see
this little boy.
He had drips
all over his hands and clothes,
and his mom was desperately
trying to clean him up
with tons of napkins.
And so we thought
there had to be a better way.
And we knew it had to be edible
and, uh, it had to be fun.
So that's how
we created the Drip Drop.
And we actually got second
in the competition,
and we also got a patent nod,
which was the best part.
The school offered
to pay for our patents.
That's fantastic.
What's your --
What's your patent on?
Basically covers the --
the shape and the size and --
A design patent.
Greiner: It's a utility patent
or a design patent?
It's a design patent,
yeah.
So, what have you
done with it?
Have you gone to sell it
to anybody?
Have you shown it to any of the
big ice cream makers or stores?
Yeah, so we went and talked to
a lot of food-industry experts,
and they all told us
that the best way
to go to market with Drip Drop
would be
to license our patent
to an ice cream cone
manufacturer.
And, uh -- And this reason
is because
the ice cream cone manufacturers
already have the customers,
already have
the ice cream store connections,
and already make products
with the same ingredients.
You are smart guys.
Thank you.
So, did you go
see any people?
So, our parents
always tell us
that you only get one chance to
make a great first impression,
which is why we want
to create the strongest pitch to
an ice cream cone manufacturer,
which is sort of
why we need you, Sharks,
to open a couple doors
and negotiate a -- a meeting.
So, how do you guys make
your prototypes, your samples?
Yeah,
so that was actually
one of our biggest challenges
along the way
is making the prototypes.
So we had to start with
a 3-D model of our Drip Drop,
and from there we turned that
into a silicone mold,
which we make
homemade batter
and pour that
into the silicone mold.
And then we just pop them
in the toaster over,
and out comes Drip Drops.
What's it cost you to make it?
What are you selling it for?
We've estimated
that the Drip Drop
will cost the ice cream cone
manufacturers
about 3.2 cents to make.
And then they'll sell that
to the ice cream stores
for about 10 cents.
How much does a cone cost?
A cone costs
about 5 cents.
So, do you think
it's a problem
that you're almost doubling
the price of the cone?
Well...
no, because, um,
I think there's a real need
for the kids and their parents,
so I think they're gonna pay
an extra quarter for it.
And it's also --
There's, um...
the need for grown-ups who just
want an extra cookie treat
at the end
of their ice cream, so...
[ Laughs ] More food.
I would put whipped cream on it,
then more sprinkles...
[ Laughter ]
...and make it
even bigger.
Chocolate chips.
Corcoran: Second layer.
Oh, my God. I'm a pig.
I would eat it all.
Sam,
I have a problem here.
Your Drip Drop
is dripping like crazy.
It's coming off the edge.
O'Leary:
It's on an angle, though.
Like -- Like we've said,
we're just making these at home
as prototypes,
so, obviously, if we went
to a manufacturer,
we would make sure
that the design is perfect
and catches all the drips.
You'd raise the lip
a little bit.
Oliver: Yeah.
And that's -- And that's where
we want to use some of the money
is to hire a food engineer
to sort of help it cinch up
on the cone the best
and look -- look the best
and help the functionality.
Herjavec:
Well, you know what?
I'll -- I'll give you
this credit.
You came out here.
You're 14 years old.
The key
is really the patent.
Yeah.
Because I think it's not
something you're gonna sell
to individual
ice cream stores.
You have to --
Cuban:
Well, I would disagree.
I would take them
to the ice cream stores
and give it to them
initially for free
so they'd want more,
you know?
So, what, Mark,
by the time they're 30,
they're making money on it?
No, no.
If there's
a bunch of people using them
and everybody's seeing them,
then you start creating demand
and you get more feedback
and you learn.
And then, you know,
once they came back for more,
you can start
charging them.
Okay.
And then
it builds from there.
You don't need to make it
perfect, all right?
You just got to get
people using it and learn.
Yeah.
But while I think it's gonna be
a great opportunity,
it's gonna take
a lot of time.
Yeah.
It's gonna take
a lot of work,
particularly
with you guys in school.
I'm gonna have to say
I'm out.
Both: All right.
Thank you so much.
Hey, guys, I completely disagree
with his strategy.
There's only one path.
You got to go
to the large manufacturers.
They got to license it.
It comes down to a patent.
There's no demand,
there's no need for a license.
That's not true.
You...
That's how
you're gonna make money.
Selling at one ice cream store
at a time,
I mean, that's
a little hobby business.
I think you guys
are really smart guys.
It's very, very clever.
Don't sell yourself short
about your ability
to call those big companies.
Okay.
All right?
I mean,
you've gotten it this far.
You got on "Shark Tank."
Oliver: Yeah.
You can pick up the phone
and make that call
or write an e-mail
and get in front of them.
Yeah, I mean, we just want a
high-profile Shark like you guys
just behind our back.
It's great to have a Shark
on your team,
but it's too early.
It's just not for me.
Okay.
I'm out.
Both: Thank you.
What's remarkable
about this product,
it's sort of timeless.
In 100 years from now,
the ice cream cone will
still be the ice cream cone.
So maybe the strategy
for you guys
is to finish high school
and then run this ring
of ice cream-stopping-dripping
technology, you know?
If that's what you want to do
by the time you get there.
Meanwhile,
you still own the patent.
That's what's unique
about this.
Um, the --
the work involved
in getting a large manufacturer
to take this on
is a fair amount of work.
I mean, it's --
even for a Shark.
They'll return our calls,
but we still got to do the work.
So while
you're in school,
I'm working for you
and I paid you $50,000 to do it.
It should be
the other way around.
The thing is,
I mean, that --
I mean, we think that,
with your money,
we can take care of everything
except for the final step
of you just calling these
ice cream cone manufacturers
and just negotiating
the deal.
Look, I admire you guys.
14 years old with a patent.
That's very cool.
Everybody said
the same thing.
I don't want
to take on the work.
I've got a full-time job
and then some.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm out.
But I think I'm gonna get
Barbara to give you $50,000.
I'm not so sure
about that.
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Barbara and Lori
are Sam and Oliver's last chance
for a deal for their ice cream
cone accessory company,
the Drip Drop.
You've got a lot of things wrong
with the business, I think.
So I'll just
give you the list.
Um, I don't think
it's a licensing deal.
I think it's an upsell
at the ice cream store.
And I think you have to go out
and sell it yourself.
That's what I think.
However, I think
you have a faulty design here.
I don't think
it looks pretty enough.
I tell you the way
to make it look really pretty --
a lot of chocolate,
a lot of sprinkles.
But even
the shape of it --
This one looks pretty.
All the good stuff,
right?
Yeah, I mean, that's --
that's what we have up here.
That's what looks great to me
up there.
I love the concept.
I think it's great.
I think it's a licensing play
because I think
you could go to one
of the big manufacturers...
Herjavec: Me, too.
...and they could distribute
when they sell their cones
to all the different
ice cream stores.
Have them do the work.
You've got the patent.
I'm not going to give you
the $50,000
because I don't want
to take 20%.
I think that you can get
on the phone, get to somebody,
have them license it,
and then keep it all.
So for that reason, I'm out.
But I wish you good luck.
Thank you.
Great idea.
And -- And for Barbara,
just -- just one thing
I want to say
is that, I mean, we're --
we're two feisty kids.
We're gonna bring this to the --
to the edge of the world.
[ Laughs ]
We're gonna make this
the biggest thing it
could possibly be.
And one thing that you're --
you're showing
to all the kids in America
by investing in us
is that dreams really do
come true, and that, uh...
Oh, you're schmoozing us now,
aren't you, sir?
I like it!
I mean, if you think we should
go for a different approach,
I mean, we're really willing
to do whatever you think --
You know, I just think there's
two faults to the product.
One is it doesn't
look cute enough.
It needs a rippled edge
like that...
Mm-hmm.
And we can make that happen.
...like a doily.
And I'm sure
that's a baking possibility.
Secondly,
it doesn't taste good.
That portion that you produced
has absolutely no taste.
-I took a bite --
-I loved mine.
No, take another bite.
There's no taste.
It was okay. It was okay.
Yeah.
So I think that
has to be brought up to speed.
That's okay.
You can fix that.
With a food engineer,
we could --
You could fix that, but I don't
think you're gonna fix it
by outsourcing it to somebody
else to solve your problem.
I agree.
The business is too young
for any kind of outsourcing.
You're the inventors.
You got to make it good.
Got to be your baby.
But I'll make you
an offer.
I'd like to be
a third partner for $50,000
with the contingency
that you fix the design
and the quality of that product.
Wow, guys.
You got an offer.
♪♪
Wow.
Barbara...
Doesn't sound good,
Oliver.
I don't like
the look on your face.
You have a deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good card player!
Yay, Barb.
Whoo! Whoo!
Together:
[ Chanting ] Barbara, Barbara,
Barbara, Barbara, Barbara.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much.
Aww.
I'm gonna marry you both
when you're 20.
Greiner:
Congratulations, guys.
Oliver: Thank you.
You won't regret it.
♪♪
Sam:
A deal with a Shark
is gonna help our school cred
enormously.
Yeah, I mean, ma--
maybe even Barbara
will pay us a visit
to our high school.
[ Laughs ]
We'll get a lot of attention
from the ladies.
♪♪
Narrator:
In Season 6, we watched
Shawnna and Kurt Feddersen
make a deal with Mark Cuban
for their women's sports fan
clothing line Gameday Couture.
My wife kills me
every single year
saying the Mavs have
horrible clothing for women.
I've already got a design.
Deal.
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
♪♪
Shawnna: Mark's invited us today
to American Airlines Center,
and we're so excited
to meet with him.
What's up, guys?
Hey.
How's it going?
Good to see you.
When Gameday came on the show,
the timing was great
'cause my wife
had been killing me
about there not being
any great women's Mavs attire.
Ta-da!
Kurt: Wow.
Shawnna: Wow.
Looks great, doesn't it?
Looks so good. Awesome!
It looks so great.
Wow.
So I gave them the contingency
my wife had to love the product,
and they
absolutely killed it.
♪♪
Make yourselves comfy.
Kurt:
The year before "Shark Tank,"
we did three quarters
of a million dollars in sales.
It's been a little over a year
since making our deal with Mark,
and we've done
over $6 million in sales.
You guys are crushing it.
Now we've got to get you
to $25 million or more.
You've got 700 stores.
We've got to get that
way higher.
I'm gonna reach out
to some of the other NBA teams
so that
we can help you scale.
We've got
a lot of work to do,
but I have
every bit of confidence
that we're gonna crush it.
Great stuff, Kurt.
Shawnna,
I really appreciate it.
Today's meeting with Mark
was invaluable.
To be able to replicate
the same concept that we
have here in stores,
it feels pretty unbelievable
to walk in
and see our products
hanging in stores.
And I have to say, I think we
delivered upon our contingency.
Narrator:
Next up are entrepreneurs
who believe they have
a lucrative spectacle
for the Sharks.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Jarrett.
I'm Raja.
And together...
Both:
We're Jarrett and Raja.
We're based
in Las Vegas, Nevada.
And our company is
Jarrett and Raja Productions --
a music magic company.
We're seeking $750,000
for 40% of our company
to help produce
a new musical magic spectacle
titled "Miracles"
for the Las Vegas Strip.
I'm a magician
who has studied
under the great
Harry Blackstone Jr.
I'm also a magician
and a pianist,
who graduated from
the Juilliard School
and played under
Sir Georg Solti.
Now, what makes us so amazingly
different than anyone else
is the unique combination
of a magician and a pianist.
Tonight,
we've brought a small sample
of our new show,
"Miracles."
Ooh!
[ Soft music plays ]
Lori, we have six different
colored handkerchiefs.
Pick a number
between one and six.
Three.
One, two, three.
The red handkerchief.
Thank you.
Sharks,
for the next 15 seconds,
whatever you do...
Don't leave your seats.
[ Chuckles ]
-Now, that's magic.
-It is magic.
[ Laughter ]
[ Upbeat music plays ]
Whoa!
Oh, my God.
[ Laughs ]
Go!
[ All gasp ]
-Bam!
-Oh, wow.
-Whoa.
-Weird.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Awesome!
[ Applause ]
Oh, my God!
Jarrett, if you do it
with Barbara,
I'll give you
the $750,000.
[ Laughs ]
Jarrett:
Come on, join our show.
That was great.
Thank you.
That was really cool.
And that's a small sample
of our show, "Miracles."
Do you have
a venue secured?
Raja:
Excellent question.
In Las Vegas, the casinos now
rent you the show room.
It is no longer the days
of paying you a salary, a fee.
They are the landlord.
It is up to the headliner
to come in with a full team,
do the marketing,
advertising,
everything
to put butts in seats.
Everything.
So, that's why
we are here today.
O'Leary: So, basically...
the risk is that it sucks
and nobody comes
and I lose $750,000.
It doesn't have to suck.
No, no, no.
I mean, it could be...
Your risk is that your show
could actually be a big success
but your costs
go out of hand...
Correct.
...and you have to
put more money into it.
There's been lots of shows
that did very well in Vegas,
but the cost went "boom."
What you're saying
is true, but --
But do you have a venue?
I'm curious.
Yeah, we're in discussions
with a venue right now.
But you need to come fully
funded before you come to them.
We are in discussions,
and the president of the hotel
is interested,
which is wonderful.
We have
an opportunity...
As long
as you pay the rent.
Exactly.
How many
does the room seat?
Generally, it seats 1,600
in this particular theater.
How much could we get
per ticket?
Tickets are $59.95
general admission.
How many shows a day?
One show a day.
What?
Why can't you guys
do two shows?
Oh, we can.
'Cause it's hard
to do the sales.
Jarrett: We can.
It's up to
if the property wants it or not.
You could drink a lot of coffee
and do three shows a day.
Well, but they also have to
fill it three times a day.
You can't sell
that many tickets.
You don't want
to have an empty room.
How many other magic acts
are there in Vegas right now?
There are
11 other magic acts.
Herjavec:
From what I understand,
in the last 12 months,
the average age of people
going to Vegas has gone down.
The most popular venue
right now
is the nightclubs
and the beach clubs.
Right.
So it's a younger demographic
going to Vegas.
Jarrett: It is.
Which is
part of the reason
why the casinos are not
willing to invest in shows
because they're not drawing in
the people like they used to.
How are you gonna get
people to come in?
Well, that's marketing.
I -- You know, it's --
it's the power of the billboards
and the cab backs and really --
So, you're gonna do like
everybody else does it.
That's expensive.
Here's the challenge.
Great act.
Thank you.
There's
11 other of other acts.
I'm going to Vegas.
I'm sitting in my hotel room.
I see a flyer.
Right.
How is it different?
'Cause you know
people in Vegas
are bombarded
with entertainment.
Yep.
Why is yours different?
You know, Robert,
our goal, really,
is to be the
next Siegfried and Roy.
I hate to be tacky
about that, but...
That's not tacky.
That's dreaming.
That's our -- That's our dream.
That's our goal.
That's our vision.
It's great to dream.
Out of all the new acts
launched every year in Vegas,
how many are successful
and how many fail?
That's a good question,
Robert.
And, you know, it depends
on the genre of the show,
the type of the show.
-That's what I was gonna say.
-It really does.
In your performance,
you'll see a graph of
the different shows...
I'm gonna say
it's pretty low.
But -- But...
I'm gonna say
it's pretty low.
It's probably like Broadway
shows or any other genre.
Cuban:
All right, guys. I agree.
It's a great show, right?
I mean -- And obviously,
you've had success doing it.
And now it's time
for your big break.
That's what you're hoping for.
I get that.
But having produced
a lot of movies,
it's hard to translate
great movies
into getting people
to go to the show.
You guys
are in the same boat.
It's just
so difficult to do.
Otherwise,
you would have already done it.
I'm out.
Corcoran:
It's such a wild bet
as to whether you'll succeed
or not on the money side.
Just seems to me so scary
and with very little control.
It is.
Taking a crapshoot.
I have to go out.
I'm out.
Herjavec: It's a bet.
I would feel more comfortable if
you had a following or a brand.
Now, regarding brand,
I want to address that.
Las Vegas
is a unique market
in that people
want to go to Vegas
and see a show
they cannot see anywhere else.
But they have 10 other
magic shows they can go see.
It's virtually impossible
to make money
the way you're trying to do it.
I'm out.
Okay.
Okay, thanks.
Thank you.
Guys, I look at risk/return --
too risky.
I'm out.
♪♪
Okay, Kevin, thank you.
Greiner:
Think about this --
Why be somewhere where you have
so much competition, right?
I'm looking
at the two of you,
and the only thing
I'm thinking is,
you should not be in Vegas.
[ Chuckles ]
I -- Seriously.
I think that you should be
in a great major city.
Just take the city of Chicago
or the city of New York.
Cuban: Right.
Tons of hotels and
tons of people that live there.
I don't think,
at least in Chicago,
that there's
any big illusion shows.
No.
You should be doing
exactly the opposite.
You should go
into the small towns....
If they move to Chicago...
...for $50 tickets.
...will you
give them the money, Lori?
I love what you're doing,
but I think you're focusing
on the wrong market.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
You guys are great.
Good luck.
All right. Thanks.
All right.
-Thank you, guys.
-Thank you very much. Thank you.
♪♪
Entertainment
is all about risks.
We understand that.
We know.
That's why we're here.
It's a risky business,
and the risks
simply outweighed, you know,
the advantages
for the Sharks.
Narrator: Next up
is an innovative product
for active parents.
♪♪
Oh, that's cool.
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Will Warne.
I'm joined today by
world-champion runner Max King
and our friend Sophie.
My partners and I
are offering
a go-to-market investment
of $500,000
in exchange for 20%
of our company -- kidRunner.
KidRunner is the world's first
and only high-performance,
multi-terrain,
hands- and arms-free kid jogger.
You know, every year,
new parents spend $1 billion
on kids' strollers and joggers.
And instead of getting
the fitness, freedom,
and performance they loved
before having kids,
they end up with a heavy,
awkward, glorified shopping cart
that increases injury
and forces them to trade off
among the things they love.
KidRunner
changes all of that.
KidRunner is safe,
comfortable,
and has the potential
to reduce injury.
With kidRunner,
we've won competitive races,
and we finished half marathons
with our kids.
We want parents
to have something beautiful,
safe, and high-performance
to run and explore with.
And with your help,
we will lead the way.
-Will, can I try it?
-Absolutely, we'd love it.
Herjavec:
I'm a big runner.
I used to run
when my kids were little.
And I never saw one
like this.
I saw
the one that you push.
Mm-hmm.
And it's hard
to run with that.
It's super hard.
Up hills, everything.
That was
my same experience.
My wife and I spent
a lot of time together running.
Will,
is that a real child?
Yeah, this Sophie.
She's 3 1/2 years old.
Can I run with her?
Absolutely.
Run around.
♪♪
Herjavec: Oh, it's --
it's really well-made.
Make a turn
when you come here, Robert.
Greiner: Yeah, go around.
O'Leary:
Run right in front of us.
Like go to the left.
Go backwards, Robert.
Run, Robert, run.
[ Laughs ]
Will: You can carry
a box of chocolates in it.
One of the things --
It's -- It's very good.
I thought when you stop,
that it would...
Cuban: Look at the kid.
Robert,
the kid's seasick.
I think the child's getting
nauseous back there.
Herjavec: Sorry, Sophie.
[ Laughter ]
Many of the comments
you guys are making
are the things that we've been
addressing and have solved.
How hard is it for Sophie
to get in and out of that?
So, let's show you.
She looks to me
like she's a little bit
stomach-sick right now.
I think
you'll be surprised.
We put
a tremendous amount of R&D
into stabilizing the rig
as you get running.
Good job, Soph.
Max: Do you want to say bye
to everybody?
Bye, Sophie.
Will: There you go.
See you, Soph.
Thank you.
Herjavec: Will,
every time a child sees Kevin,
it's the reaction we get.
[ Laughter ]
Let's just look
at the market sales.
Let's assume this is
the very best device to run with
with a child behind you.
I'm gonna give you that,
okay?
Okay.
Now I'm asking myself
the marketing problem.
I have to find the customer
that's a subset of the parents,
because not everybody
wants to run with their child,
so it's a subset
of that market.
So, 4 million new kids born
in the United States every year.
This is just
the United States.
400,000 of those parents
call themselves runners
the day that kid is born.
I'll tell you
the flaw in that.
When I run
longer distances...
Mm-hmm.
...I'd want
to see my child.
I don't know if I'd want
to run a long distance
and assume that the kid is okay
behind me.
First of all,
the kid can't fall out
because
we've met or exceeded
all of the ASTM safety
standards -- five-point harness.
Besides which, a kid
would scream right away.
I'm sure of it.
You're never gonna not know
the kid is there,
and, Robert,
while you're running,
it's designed
so that you can just look back.
While you're running with a pram
or a stroller in front of you,
you can't see your child.
How do you get it
into the car?
So, the wheels -- quick-release
wheels off, the top --
Show me.
So, these we bolted in,
but they are designed
as quick-release wheels.
Why?
Why did you
have to bolt them in?
Because we wanted
to tune this rig
so that it
was completely on sync,
because this is
our go-to-market prototype.
♪♪
So, you're not
selling this yet?
This is a prototype.
This is a go-to-market
investment opportunity.
[ Chuckles ]
He was clear about that
up front.
I love the way
you said that.
This is a go-to-market
investment opportunity
for the world's only
high-performance kid jogger.
What does it cost?
So, three-phase go $750.
Oh.
Whoa!
Well, you'd think,
but not "Whoa" at all.
No, you're right.
Who's not telling you
"Whoa"?
I've seen prams
for $2,500.
How much money
have you guys put into this?
So, we've put in
about $73,000.
That's all, okay.
And do you have advance orders
on your product?
So, we've got a sign-up list
of over 1,200 people
that have told us they want
to be first with an opportunity.
And put a deposit down.
Kickstarter or Indiegogo?
We did do
a Kickstarter campaign.
What was your ask?
Our Kickstarter campaign
was organized
around building prototypes
for our elite and everyday
mom and dad ambassador teams.
And they run, test, experience
our prototypes, our R&D process.
To solve the remaining
10% of the --
And how much
were you looking for?
Why would somebody on
Kickstarter give you money?
We were asking
for, uh, $100,000.
How much did you raise?
$6,000 to $7,000,
but I'll tell you why.
Wow.
Ouch.
Oh.
Only $6,000 to $7,000?
We were deluged by people
saying, "I want a kid runner.
I don't want to sponsor one
of your ambassador athletes."
O'Leary: I'm still waiting
for you to tell me
how I sell
$5 million of it.
Where we are right now is we've
set up retail ambassadors.
We have an online B2C site.
We have
an e-commerce plug-in.
You love
this ambassador thing.
The ambassador program has been
really important for us,
partly to get ahead
of some of the questions
you guys have been asking.
But for us,
that was two years ago.
So, we've been asking
the questions you guys
have been asking for years.
Cuban: Will.
Yeah.
Why has it taken you years
to get to a 95% ready point?
Well, it's taken us
three years
because the technical design,
engineering solutions for this
are radically complex.
Corcoran:
Will, I want to say something.
Yeah.
This is what I'm really
disturbed about.
I think you're the type of
person who's a careful plotter.
So I don't believe that
you're the kind of entrepreneur
that is really going to get it
out there and done finally
with a lot of sales.
And so I would definitely
have to be out.
Okay.
And for those of you
who are potentially still in,
I want to disavow
everything you just heard,
although I appreciated
hearing it.
Please do.
Oh!
Yeah, so,
it is a child sports product.
You have to be safe.
Of course!
You have to be careful.
And you're gonna be saying that
forever.
But, no, we take -- we launch
our pre-order site in five days.
This was an R&D project.
So three years to solve
for the first time...
Did you take the --
...safety
and high-performance.
Will, did you take deposits
from any of those?
So, we will ask
for a $200 deposit
once we launch
our pre-order campaign.
Right, exactly!
See, you --
She is exactly right.
It takes nothing for you to set
it up and say, "You know what?
If we don't get it,
we'll give you your money back."
You got to take orders.
Eventually, you got
to stop making it perfect.
I'm out.
Perfection is the enemy
of profitability.
Now, I get
you got to protect kids.
You can't have
any mistakes there.
But Barbara
is exactly right.
And I have a feeling you are
just such a perfectionist
at getting this right
that it would take
73 years
before you actually
shipped this thing.
I'm out.
I also agree with Barb.
But I'll set that aside.
My problem
with the product
is I feel it's very
unengaging for the child.
And then
the safety aspect.
And I'm not a runner,
so I could be all wet.
But that's just my feeling.
I'm out.
O'Leary:
My biggest problem with this
deal is getting the customer.
I've lived my whole career
in the educational market,
where we tried to capture kids
when they were born
and sell to them
till they were 7.
There has never been a company
that's solved for it, just ever.
It's always been
the highest cost --
the customer-acquisition fees.
I think that's gonna be
a big challenge for you.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
I really appreciate
your feedback.
Thank you very much.
Good luck, guys.
Pleasure.
Great experience
for start to finish.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Good luck.
♪♪
Our commitment
to parents and runners
is to give them something
that they love,
that's beautiful,
that's high-performance,
and that's safe.
And I think
people are gonna be really happy
that we took the time
to get it right.
Something happened today that's
never happened on "Shark Tank."
What's that?
The four of us
agreed with Barbara.
Whoa!
Narrator:
Next up is a product line
to make life easier
for parents.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name's Brenda Lee Feldman,
and I'm from Austin, Texas.
And I'm here today
seeking $400,000
in exchange
for a 10% stake
in my thriving children's
products company, InchBug.
Kids love juice boxes,
and parents love
the convenience of them.
But then there's that accidental
juice-box squeeze.
[ Laughter ]
Kids can't help it --
They have to squeeze
those juice boxes and pouches.
So, in order to save
those cute outfits,
your furniture,
and even
the back seat of your car,
I have created a solution --
MyDrinky.
MyDrinky is a two-piece,
adjustable juice-box holder,
and it comes
in four colors.
It is a no-brainer,
no-stainer.
So, Sharks, what I brought today
is a MyDrinky sample.
And then I also brought
some Orbit Labels,
which is the first product
that I invented,
'cause we're not
a one-product company.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
If you want to grab
three things.
Here,
I'll give Lori hers.
She has
a hard time getting there.
Greiner: Thank you.
He's such a gentleman.
Oh, good. Purple.
Here's a baby bottle
for you.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
Here you go,
Mr. Wonderful.
Brenda, what --
Is this milk?
Yes, it is.
It's real milk.
How do you get it in?
You're gonna use
these two fingers,
and you're gonna press both
nose buttons at the same time...
Oh, I see.
...and pull the top off.
Okay, and then?
Then, you're gonna place
the juice box into the base.
Okay.
Place it back down
onto the base.
It's just a holder.
Yes, it's holder
so kids can't squeeze
those juice boxes and pouches.
Clever.
What did you expect?
[ Laughs ]
-What were you doing?
-Well, lookit.
She turned it upside down
like the straw wasn't gonna --
-[ Gasps ]
-Most kids will think of that.
-Yes, and that's --
-So what?
The parents
are gonna try to stop them.
It doesn't stop it
from leaking.
Right.
It stops the squeeze.
There's no guarantee
on leaking.
But one thing
that's wonderful about this
is the fact
that it adjusts in height.
It accommodates all these
juice boxes and pouches.
Brenda, I'm thinking
what's wonderful about it
is you must have sold
a ton of it
because you're asking $4 million
value for the Drinky-poo.
That's a lot a dough.
Okay,
of the MyDrinky product,
I've actually sold $50,000 worth
of this particular product.
Wow.
Cuban: But wait.
There's got to be more.
Surprise me
with the other products.
There is.
There is more.
That's what I want you --
If you want to take a look.
What's this product?
That's -- That was
my initial invention.
10 years ago,
I invented that product.
How does it work?
And basically, what it is,
if you look at it closely,
it is a label for your
baby bottles and sippy cups.
Oh, so your product
is just this.
Yes.
So, how much of that
have you sold?
Over the past 10 years,
I've sold $15 million.
You're kidding.
I can't believe that.
Why were you even tell us
about the Drinky guy?
What about the past year?
Past year, $2 million.
And how did you --
And how did you do it?
Distribution, first of all,
was out of my home.
Okay, but then...
Out of my garage.
Did you do it online?
We're trying to figure out
how you were selling them.
Right.
So, we sold them
on a website.
I'm just curious
because Robert's name
is actually cut into this.
Oh, it is?
It's not written on.
That's correct.
That's right.
So, do you stamp this out
and then send them?
Yes, we personalize
all of that at our office.
So, it's personalized.
So, let me just kind of give you
some history
so you understand
kind of where I'm coming from.
My company is InchBug,
which I created in 2004.
So, I started this business
out of the garage of my home.
And I grew it the first year
from $150,000 worth of sales
to $850,000
the second year.
What does one cost?
They're actually sold
in a package of four.
And they're sold
for $12.95.
How much does it cost you
to make them?
How much --
$1.44.
O'Leary: $1.44?
Personalized, as well?
Personalized, as well.
Listen,
you're the real deal.
What are you selling, though,
Orbit Labels or MyDrinky?
What I'm offering to you
is I'm offering you
a portion of my business.
So, it's
everything together.
That's correct.
Is this tried-and-true?
Do you know if this is working?
Yes, it's
absolutely working.
Only to $50,000, though.
That's it. Well --
O'Leary: When you compare
the success of the Orbit Labels
versus MyDrinky,
MyDrinky's a dog.
The labels are where
the action is.
I don't think
this is ever gonna be
what the Orbit Labels are.
Let's hear her out.
Well, let me
explain to you
why those sales
are where they're at.
Our manufacturer is based here
in the U.S., had two plants.
One plant burned down.
But what ended up happening is
they start shifting their work,
appeasing
their larger clients.
Okay?
So, we have had a big issue
with just inventory.
So, Orbit Labels,
where does it flatline?
Okay, so right now,
we're at $2 million.
Per year.
And that's actually
been for the past four years.
So, they've leveled out.
It's flat. It's flat.
So, right now it's been
just a small incline.
Now,
this particular product
is one that I think
would be wildly successful
in the retail market.
-Whoa.
-And this is --
Have you ever played in the
retail space with a product?
No, and that's why I need --
that's why I need a partner.
I swear to you,
you are lucky.
It looks so much better
from the outside.
And even if you
get into the stores,
you have to worry
about your inventory,
monitoring, them sending
inventory back to you.
It's a huge problem.
A whole different business.
You've built a franchise online,
and you have customers
that are very happy
to buy from you online.
Yeah.
Why mess with retail?
I hate Drinky-poo in retail.
That sucks.
Narrator:
All sharks are still in,
but they are skeptical
about Brenda's desire
to take her kids' drink holder,
MyDrinky, into retail.
You should just focus
on the label.
You've built a franchise online,
and you have customers
that are very happy
to buy from you online.
Yeah.
Why mess with retail?
I hate Drinky-poo in retail.
That sucks.
I mean, 'cause you
have to give half your margin.
Who wants that?
Okay, we've been in our business
for almost 10 years.
If you walk into
any daycare facility,
you'll most likely find
one of our labels there.
Got it.
So we want to capitalize
off of that.
Greiner:
You can give it a whirl,
but to take
a lot of inventory,
get stock into stores,
if it doesn't work
and maybe get it back,
that would be
a problem for you.
Well,
I know there's interest,
because I am negotiating
with a big-box store.
Herjavec: Yeah,
but, Brenda, don't forget,
people in retail
like new things,
but it may not
sell through.
You have $2 million worth
of basically recurring revenue.
You're living the dream,
and the grass is always greener.
Retail is hard.
I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Cuban: Look, Brenda, you're
taking on a whole new business,
but you're not really playing
into your core competency,
which is customizing.
And you're selling
$2 million worth, right?
You're killing it.
But instead, you're --
you're trying to go in this
whole new world of retail,
which doesn't play to
the thing that makes you
different and better
and has really
made you your money.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
That's -- That's disappointing.
Brenda, I think the beauty of
a juice box is it's one step --
pop the straw,
and end of story.
You managed to take a simple
process that every mom loves
and make it complicated.
I would never
spend the time
opening that up, putting the box
in, putting the cap on,
then putting the straw in.
It defeats
the whole purpose.
So you're here selling
really a waning business
with your eye
on the wrong ball,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Well, I-I do believe there is
future for this product.
Greiner:
What I think is...
It's like the saying,
if it ain't broke, don't fix it.
If you've got a winner,
don't quit it, don't change it.
Just keep going with it
until it doesn't work anymore.
You're gonna make it,
and I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
Thank you.
Appreciate that.
O'Leary:
Okay, here's my thoughts.
Okay.
Usually, when a company
comes into Shark Tank,
it's either going to work
and you're gonna have
a huge growth trajectory
or it's gonna fail
and we're gonna lose our money.
I would give you
the $400,000.
We agree on a royalty.
Your margins are huge.
You could probably pay me
a dollar on every one you sell
until I get back
three times on my money,
and then it goes away.
There's no perpetuity here,
but I own 5% of your business,
which keeps me interested
in working with you.
The beautiful thing about your
business that attracts me to it
and why I'd like
to work with you is --
Take Wicked Good Cupcakes, run
by two women, and we want to --
Oh, no.
Not Wicked again.
Will you shut up,
Barbara?
It's important
information here.
I'm so tired
of hearing about that.
Wicked again. That's an
offer from a pig, Brenda.
You should know that.
Well, how are you
gonna help me?
O'Leary: You'll meet
my social-media team.
They're amazing.
I will put you on
to everything we do
on television,
print, and online.
He's asking three times
on repayment. He's nuts.
Brenda, listen.
I don't need Barbara
to negotiate my deals,
'cause she actually isn't
very good with numbers.
He's a greedy man.
You know that.
It doesn't matter.
My deal is very fair to you,
frankly, because --
But I am negotiating
with a big-box store.
I'm just doing
the final paperwork.
Oh, you love
the retail siren.
Well, I just want
to let you know...
You know, I'm sorry.
I'm not going there.
...I probably have about
$1 million worth of growth
anticipated for next year
with this product.
Brenda, I'm gonna put -- I'm
gonna put a contingency on it.
They're ordering
$1 million worth?
I don't want to invest
in a business
that is going into retail.
You have no idea
what you're doing, trust me.
You're gonna
take capital...
Well --
...and you're gonna
tie it up in inventory,
and it's going to float
for 90 to 100 days
before you get it back,
and some of this product
may not sell.
If that's your burning desire
and you want to do that,
I don't want
to invest in you, okay?
Well, I-I feel
as I'm on the path to it,
because I'm --
I'm negotiating with someone.
I understand that,
but it doesn't mean you --
This is
a critical moment.
He is telling you
"I do not see that vision,
and if you do it,
I'm not going to give you
the investment."
You know, I feel confident
that I can --
I can grow this business.
What I want to do is grow
a wholesale arm of InchBug.
It's binary.
I told you what I want in --
in you and how I can help you.
Herjavec: All right, Brenda,
you have an offer.
What are you gonna do?
Okay, so, I thank you very much
for your offer.
But I just cannot see myself
giving up this opportunity
to really exponentially
grow my business.
Then I have to say it.
You're dead to me, Brenda.
Thank you.
Corcoran: Thank you.
♪♪
I think Kevin lost today,
'cause I think MyDrinky
is going to make it in retail.
I think it's gonna be
wildly successful,
and I'll continue
working hard.
There's no reason to quit
at this point.
She's killing it.
Why does she want to do
something different like that?
-She is so smart, so smart.
-I feel sorry for her.
She's bored after 10 years
of doing the same old thing.
O'Leary: You know, there's
nothing -- You're right.
She's bored, and now she's gonna
go blow a million bucks.